[Musica]
[Applauso]
armonia dal greco unione accordo e per
fugare ogni dubbio sulla nostra levatura
culturale e sulla nostra preparazione in
merito vi diciamo subito che questa
definizione modestamente l'abbiamo
trovata stamattina su internet
la nostra è una storia di armonia
dieci anni fa tre musicisti siciliani
decidono di formare un gruppo così come
si fa a 14 anni nei garage nelle cantine
e cominciano a condividere delle cose a
questa combriccola si unirà anche
riccardo samperi nostro co produttore e
poeta del suono come vi dicevo
cominciamo a condividere i primi
risultati primi successi ma soprattutto
la tanta fatica i tanti insuccessi
cominciamo a condividere i viaggi i
sacrifici le stanze d'albergo che non
sono sempre single e a volte sono triple
con un letto singolo è un letto
matrimoniale
la felicità non è reale se non è
condivisa recita una bellissima frase di
un film splendido e per noi la musica
deve essere condivisa in maniera sincera
e autentica sia da chi la produce che da
chi la riceve del resto l'armonia non è
altro che condivisione di note ma
maestro tidone vi dica ci dia una
definizione di armonia così per il
pubblico mondiale che ci segue in parole
semplici e sento come sa fare lei
sicuramente tanto diciamo che l'armonia
è uno dei tre elementi costitutivi della
musica insieme a ritmo e melodia
l'armonia e lo sviluppo funzionale della
relazione tra le note interni di
intervalli sia simultanei come negli
accordi sia susseguenti come nelle
melodie né gli arpeggi e lo sviluppo
relazionale tra gli accordi che
detengono la struttura del brano nonché
progressione armonica possibilità da
quanti di voi hanno capito
passata la mano nessuno ecco perfetto
maestro burgio ci illumini lei la prego
carissimi maestri premier il semestre io
direi che è il caso di fare un esempio
pratico
andiamo alla pratica allora facciamo
così io adesso vi suona una melodia
molto semplice con un accompagnamento
altrettanto semplice fatto da tre note
le cosiddette triani è un po come i
colori primari armonia e melodia
sicuramente vi daranno dei ricordi delle
immagini
[Musica]
mi ha suscitato questa immagine non
siamo ad essere stato bene adesso senza
cambiare la melodia
visionerò un'armonia più complessa un po
come aggiungere delle sfumature ai
colori primari possiamo in sostanza dire
che l'armonia e veicolo di emozioni e
quindi cambiando l'armonia cambieranno
anche le vostre sensazioni ad esempio
malinconia
[Musica]
non situazioni non si sa se adesso vedo
gioia vedo giovani alle docce uscita
[Musica]
carissimo mestre filone io ho questa
domanda da farle ma secondo lei gli
accordi si possono concatenare fra di
loro
certamente si possono concatenare quelle
che si chiamano progressioni armoniche
ce ne sono di svariato tipo nei secoli
nei secoli sono state utilizzate
esplorate ma alcune sono più state
utilizzate più famose come la cadenza
classica le hanno utilizzate tutti i più
grandi compositori come mozart beethoven
ma anche metallica burgio questa
bellezza classica e poi mandiamo nel
mondo del jazz ci sono alcune
professioni tipiche delle tonalità gen
sisti che dalle più semplici e facciamo
un esempio
[Musica]
a quelle più complesse per fare un
esempio prendiamo un brano del grande
sassofonista john coltrane che ha
pensato e sviluppato da una progressione
armonica che si chiama appunto alcol tra
il changes il brano lo faremo sentire in
un brano che si chiama giant steps aveva
un piccolo estratto
[Musica]
quindi quindi potremmo anche parlare di
armonia come equilibrio tra gli
strumenti cioè di arrangiamento dando
una connotazione per esempio
antropologica un ritmo a un luogo per
esempio se john coltrane fosse nato in
emilia romagna come avrebbe suonato ho
pensato questo brano one to one two
three
[Musica]
67 se john coltrane fosse nato in
giamaica
[Musica]
ma vogliamo superarci adesso adesso
vogliamo andare sul campo del difficile
la sperimentazione free jazz degli anni
sessanta settanta che era proprio
insomma una bella era una musica di
rottura di raccolti sicuramente di
rottura la colpa se ok ok
[Musica]
beh adesso grazie
vogliamo chiudere il nostro incontro con
un gran finale nel senso che il brano è
solo un gran finale di tutti i brani di
the le armonie con tutte le armonie dei
bei brani esistenti del pop del jazz e
del soul
dopo john cage che ha composto 4 minuti
e 33 famosissimo brano noi abbiamo
modestamente composto un minuto e 33 con
l'aiuto di un timer con l'aiuto di un
tackle noi cercheremo di chiudere al
secondo 0
questa serie di finali e abbiamo voluto
dedicare questo brano a ted è infatti il
brano si intitola finalmente
[Musica]
[Applauso]